I want to take up in volume 4 at October the 8th 1901 and I have a VIP on this particular
message as well and it's about the value of the intention. Now in the last number of
messages we've had quite a lot on the importance of placing the intention and the value of
it so here we're going to have one that underlines the value of it. This morning I struggled
very much in waiting for my adorable Jesus. However while waiting for him I did as much
as I could to unite everything I was doing in my interior with the interior of our Lord.
Now see there's the very important thing that everything you do you unite with everything
in him so that you take on his infinite merit and then do it in the divine will and it's
on a divine level and therefore it's endless. In tending to give him Louisa said all the
glory and reparation which is most holy humanity gave him. Now while I was doing this blessed
Jesus came and he told me my daughter when a soul makes use of my humanity as the means
to operate be it even a thought a breath or any act they are like as many gems that come
out of my humanity and present themselves before the divinity and since they come come
through my humanity they have the same effects as my operating had on the earth and Louisa
said all Lord I feel a doubt. How can it be that with the simple intention in operating
be it even in the smallest things which considered in themselves are trivial and empty. It seems
that the mere intention of union with you and of pleasing you alone fills them and you
elevate them in that supreme way making them appear as their greatest thing. So the heading
I have for the next paragraph is what is it that gives value to our acts. And my daughter
he said the operating of the creature is empty in other words what we do has no value be
it even a great work rather it is the union with me and the very simple aim at pleasing
me. Now in John's gospel Jesus says I only do what pleases my father the very simple
aim of pleasing me that fills it and since my working would be it even a breath accesses
all the works of creatures together in an infinite way this is why it renders it so
great. Besides don't you know that one who makes use of my humanity as the means to do
his actions comes to nourish himself from the fruits of my humanity and to feed himself
from my own food we literally feed off Christ and the fruits of his life. Furthermore is
it perhaps not the good intention that makes a man holy and the evil intention that makes
man perverted. Now you have a good teaching on this in the prophet Ezekiel chapter 18
from verses 21 to 32. So this is not a new idea. One does not always do different things
but with the same actions one is sanctified and another is perverted according to the
intention. Now while he was saying this Louisa said I saw a flourishing tree inside the
Lord so she's seeing the Jesus as the tree of life so that can be divine John 15 or it
can be the mustard seed he was very humbled in giving those examples. I saw a flourishing
tree inside our Lord filled with beautiful fruits and I saw that those souls who operated
to please God alone of St. Therese of Lisieux is famous for that and through his humanity
were inside of him upon that tree so literally feeding off the tree of life and his humanity
served as a dwelling place for these souls. But how so very scarce was their number is
the tragedy. So I want to give you Luke 644 I want to give you Revelation 22 I want to
give you Sam 1 and Revelation 2 7. So October the 11th 1901 we're dealing with the silence
of Jesus and the most necessary nourishment of peace.
After various days of privation and of silence this morning as Jesus came he continued to
be silent and even though I kept him almost always with me as much as I tried I could
not manage to have him speak a single word. He seemed to have something in his interior
that embittered him so much so as to render him taciturn. Something which he did not want
me to know. Now while Jesus was with me I seemed to see the Queen Mother and upon seeing
Jesus with me she told me it's you who keeps him well thank goodness he's with you for
if he has to pour out his just fury. If he is with you you hold him back. My daughter
pray that he would hold back the scourges for the evil ones are all ready to come out.
Now these evil ones are the Communists and the Marxist atheists and the Freemasons and
others but they see themselves bound by a supreme power that prevents them. So what you
have here is that God's will is opposing their will as much as possible and they are opposing
God's will as much as possible. That's called war okay. And so blessed mother was delighted
that was he was with Louisa because at least that would hold back the chastisement somehow.
And she said even if divine justice will permitted since they would not be able to do it when
they pleased to there would be this good that they will recognize the divine authority over
them. Now the people who are going to blast the 20th century with this awful heresy of
communism and Marxist atheism. Blessed mother says that if they are held back and they're
not able to do what they want to do in the timescale that they've given themselves they
will be forced to acknowledge that there is a God over their heads. There is a divine
authority there. And they will say we did this because we were given the power from above.
Now that's John 1911 where Jesus said to Pilate you would have no power over me unless it was
given to you from above. So she said my daughter what a war is being nourished in the moral world.
Okay it's horrifying to see it. Now I have to remind you that Pope Leo the 13th is still
in charge in Rome and he was the one who had the vision of a conversation between Satan and Christ
in which Satan asked for a hundred years to destroy the church and he was given the permission
that's the amazing thing because the trial that Satan would put upon the church would
sift the church like wheat. And if you remember just before the passion that Jesus told Peter
that Satan was going to sift all of them like wheat and they all failed in the most awful way.
John recovered the fastest okay. So there was going to be this terrible trial of the church
in the 20th century and we're still reaping the bitter fruits of it in the 21st century.
Yeti said that the first nourishment that should be sought in society in families and by each
soul should be that of peace. Peace should be the nourishment that keeps us alive. That's the
Philippians 4, 7, the peace that passes all understanding and guards our hearts and our minds
in Christ Jesus. Without peace they will bring neither health nor true sanctity. Now people who
are continuously disturbed their health is not able to take the terrible stress and the health
breaks down. And true sanctity of course it means remaining in total and complete trust in God no
matter what's going on. Yet this nourishment is so necessary and solitary it has been discarded
by today's world and they want nothing but turbulence and wars and he said my daughter pray pray.
That's pray that a divine justice won't wipe them out and be that somehow the chastisement
that have to be sent will change hearts. So October the 14th 1901 Jesus shows himself like a flash
and makes her louisa understand something about the divine attributes. So here we're going to learn
something about the blessed trinity themselves. So it's good to write that at the top of your page.
Blessed Jesus comes in passing almost like a flash and in that flash he releases from his interior
a special distinction of one of his attributes and then another. How many things he makes me
understand in that flash? You see time is our thing. God is outside of time so everything happens
in a flash. But once the flash has withdrawn my mind remains in the dark and is unable to adapt
itself to repeating what it has understood in that flash. So I want to give you Sam 36 verse 9.
Lord in your light we see light and of course when he withdraws that light we see nothing.
More so since it is about things that touch on the divinity and the human tongue struggles
to try and repeat them and the more it tries the more mute it remains. So it's 1 Corinthians 2 9
and 2 Corinthians 12. Even more in these things it is always a newborn little girl. But obedience
wants me to try and say something and so I'll have to try. It seems to me that God contains
all goods within himself in such a way that finding all goods which God contains within him
one does not need to go anywhere else to see the vastness of his boundaries. No. But he alone is
enough to find everything that is his. In other words you don't find it outside of him you find
inside. That's like saying if you want to know me come and live with me we can only
really get to know someone by getting inside of that character and personality and living with it.
It's the same that the more we know God and the more union we have with God the more we understand him.
Now in one flash he showed a special distinction of his beauty. Now as we go on in these writings
he's going to mention his beauty over and over and over again. Remember St. Guston,
old beauty so ancient and so new late have I loved thee. But that beauty has to do with harmony and
peace and joy and order. Everything to do with God is that so that everything is in its right place
and doing the right thing. It's immense beauty and Louisa is not the only saint that says that
God's beauty is beyond description. But who can say how beautiful he is? I can only say that all
the angelic and human beauties, the beauties of the varieties of flowers and fruits, the splendid
Asia of the starry heavens, would seem to which seem to enchant us and speak to us of a supreme beauty
that as we look at them compared to his beauty our mere shadows or a breath that God has sent forth
from his beauty which he contains within himself. In other words it's not possible to describe it.
That is they are little drops of Jew compared with the immense waters of the sea. I move on from my
mind begins to get lost. In another flash he showed me a special distinction about the attribute of
charity or love because God is love, one John four seven to seventeen. But how can I am miserable
one open my mouth about this attribute, Trice Holy, which is the very source from which all the
other attributes derive. In other words the essence of God is love. He's the source and the origin
of all love and life and beauty and grace and all the rest. I will only say that I understand
what I understood with regard to the human nature. So I understood that as God creates us
this attribute of love that's divine love pours into us and fills us completely of itself.
So in other words she's saying we are created out of love. God intended us to be conceived
in love. He intended us to be nourished in love. He intended us to grow up in love. He intended
us to be educated in love. He intended us when we would reach maturity that we would be ready to
pass on this love to others. And he intended us to die in love so that in death we could actually
go to the very source of love. Now that's Ephesians chapter three from verses 16 to 21.
That was his intention and that's the reason why there's nothing that satisfies a human being
except love. We can try and satisfy ourselves with material things, we drink, drugs, sex, anything
we can think of. World travel, experience, education, anything you like but the only thing that satisfies
is love. And if the soul responded to this love being filled with the breath of the love of God
her very nature should be transmuted into the love of God. Now our blessed mother of course was
able to respond because she had this divine charity from the very first instant of her being and
there was no sin to block it in any way. But as the soul keeps diffusing herself
in the love of creatures now really diffusing herself is not the best description there.
We would say dissipating herself in the love of creatures that is in human relationships
or of pleasures that's the entertainment that the modern life thinks you can't live without
or of interests that is in all kinds of projects or businesses that you get involved in that you
have a stake in or any other thing that divine breath keeps going out of the soul. So it keeps
diluting this divine love that was given in the beginning and if the soul arrives at dissipating
herself in everything now I think dissipating is the word. If you write it down in dissipating
herself and everything she becomes empty of divine love. Now if you're empty of divine love and you
die there's no way you can go to heaven because love is the only baggage that is accepted in heaven.
But since the soul cannot enter heaven if she's not a complex of most pure charity fully divine
okay because we've been told this before if the soul is saved this breath which she received in
being created she will acquire again by dint of fire in the purging flames of purgatory.
Now the complex of pure charity I want to give you Galatians 5 22 these are the fruits of the
spirit the holy spirit is charity so it's love joy peace patience kindness goodness and so on
and all of them have to harmonize inside of us to bring God's harmony and beauty into our souls.
So if you dare to go to the other side without having your bags full of divine love then you
have to go and acquire it in the purging flames of purgatory. And only when she comes to the point
of overflowing with this divine charity can she actually leave purgatory. So if our baggage has
very little love in it when we pass from this world to the next it means a very long purgatory
and purgatory is not a place you really want to go. The pain is too great because the pain is divine
pain it's soul pain and it is so much greater than anything it could imagine in the body that you
can't even compare it. So who knows what an extremely long stop that she has to make in that
expo to replace. Now if the creature should be so what must God be? I believe I'm speaking much
nonsense but I am not surprised because I'm not at all some learned one I am always an ignorant one
and if there's anything of truth in these writings it's not mine but God's which Jesus will affirm
many times and I remain always the little ignorant one. So October the 21st we come back to the
upright intention again now you'll have noticed that in all the recent messages the emphasis is on
the intention we've got to know what we're doing why we're doing it and we've got to keep offering
all the time. This morning on coming blessed Jesus seemed to be making a circle with his arms
almost to enclose me inside of it and while clasping me he told me my daughter when the soul
does everything for me that is the motivation is love of God alone everything remains enclosed
in this circle nothing goes out now that circle is the divine will we're staying in that incredible
circle of the divine will so nothing will go out if the intention is right even if it's a sigh a
heartbeat or just any movement everything enters into me and in me everything is numbered
now he seems to me in one two three four five six and I as recompense pour them back into the soul
but doubled with grace in such a way that as the soul pours them once again into me and I into her
she comes to acquire a surprising capital of grace all this is my way of delighting that is to give
the creature what she has given to me as if it was her own always adding from my own one who with
his ingratitude prevents me from giving what I want prevents my innocent delights if then one does
not operate in me everything goes out of my circle dispersed like dust by a mighty wind and therefore
that part of our lives is wasted so october the 25th 1901 this is the privation again
I went through various days of doubts and fears about my state believing that it was all a crafting
of my fantasy you know she goes through this quite frequently and sometimes my mind would
become so fixated on this that I reached the point of lamenting and regretting with our Lord saying
what pain what disgrace has been mine to be a victim of my own fantasy I believed I was seeing
you but instead it was all the hallucination of my fantasy I believed I was fulfilling your will
by remaining in this bed for such a long time but who knows whether this also will be the fruit
of my fantasy Lord the mere thought of this gives me pain it frightens me your will used to sweeten
everything but this embitters me down to the marrow of my bones naturally if she's just sitting there
in a bed doing nothing only being utterly deceived I mean that would break you please give me the
strength to get out of this imaginary state and I would get so fixated as to be unable to distract
myself so much so that I reached the point of thinking that this fantasy would prepare me
a place in hell though I tried to snap out of it by saying well then I will make use of my fantasy
to be able to love him in hell now other saints have said the same thing when they were grievously
tempted they said well if I do arrive in hell because the devil would tell them they're going straight
to hell that there will be somebody in hell who loves God now hell is not hell if there's somebody
who loves God so the devil usually leaves them alone at that point now while I was in this fixation
blessed Jesus wanted to increase the pain of my position by moving within my interior saying do
not pay attention to this otherwise I will leave you this is going on for four volumes and he's
trying to tell her not to pay so much attention to how she's feeling and all of the rest of it and
to stop this scrutinizing because there was such a problem in the early part of the 20th century in
the church of screw velocity and he's trying to get her off this continuous examination examination
examination to put her attention completely on him so he says don't pay attention to this otherwise
I will leave you and will show you whether it is I who comes or it is your fantasy that hallucinates
but she says in spite of this I did not then get concerned saying ah yes he will not have the
courage to do it he's so good but he did he actually did it it is needless to say what I went through
for several days without Jesus I it would be too long the mere remembering of it freezes the blood
in my veins therefore I move on now after I said all this to the confessor it seemed that he became
my mediator and we began to pray together that's Matthew 18 19 if two of you agree concerning any
matter I will ratify it in heaven we began to pray together that the Lord would dain to come
and I felt I was losing consciousness that is going into ecstasy and Jesus made himself seen from
very far away almost scowling at me for he did not want to come I would not dare but the confessor
insisted uniting the intention now notice the intention that he would share the crucifixion with
me so to come content the confessor Jesus drew near and shared with me the pains of the cross
then as if he had made peace with me he told me it was necessary that I deprive you of me
otherwise you would not have convinced yourself whether it is I or your fantasy
privation is beneficial to make one know where things come from and the preciousness of the object
that is lost and to hold it in greater esteem when it is reacquired you see the the problem is that
familiarity breeds contempt and if Jesus keeps coming all the time then she's just going to take
it for granted because that's the way we are and he says that if he has to stay away and leave her
in privation she will begin to appreciate the enormity of the gift that's been given to her
so November the 22nd 1901 the self carries the mark of all ruin
this is very important we've been told from volume one denial of self and so on
so after going through most bitter days of tears privation and silence my poor heart could bear no
more the torment of being outside of my center so she's outside of this circle that she's supposed
to be in all the time is so great that I'm continuously battered amid mid-densed waves of a fierce storm
in a state of strong violence such that I would suffer death at each moment and what's more
I cannot die so I want to give you Sam 63 and Sam 42 for that as I was in this position Jesus made
himself seen for just a little and he told me my daughter when the soul does the will of someone
else in everything it is said that she has trust in that person therefore she lives from someone
else's will not from her own in the same way when the soul does my will in everything I say
that she has faith now you need to put an envy beside that he says we have faith when we do his
will in everything so divine will and faith are branches produced by the same tree trunk
and since faith is simple faith and divine will produce a third branch and that is simplicity
now simplicity is the exact opposite of complexity
and the Lord tries to bring us into simplicity because our experience of being an adult in society
makes us complex creatures and he has to try and bring us back to a position of great simplicity
so that he can work with us and in us and here is how the soul comes to re-acquire the characteristics
of a dove in everything don't you want to be my dove well that's the song of songs chapter 5 verse
2 John 1 32 and Luke 3 22 on another occasion the dove of course represents peace and the dove
rested on the head of Jesus in his baptism to point him out as the prince of peace and also to point
him out as the anointed messiah on another occasion another day he told me my daughter pearls gold
gems the most precious things are kept in good custody inside some safe with double locks
what do you fear then if i keep you in good custody inside the safe of holy obedience
the most safe custody in which not one but two keys keep the door well closed so as to preclude
the entrance of any thief and even of a shadow of any defect only the self carries the mark of
ruin but without the self everything is in safety so i want to give you Romans 8 31 to 39th at the
very end of the passage from Romans 8 where Paul says nothing can separate us from the love of Christ
except ourselves nothing outside of us can do it so December the 27th 1901 Jesus is the administrator
of the most holy trinity to creatures we would call him the CEO it's needless to talk about my poor
state about how i have reduced myself it would be wanting to embit her and deepen the wounds of my
soul therefore i let everything pass in silence making and offering to the lord which is correct
this morning while i was crying over the loss of my adorable Jesus the confessor came and gave
me the obedience to pray the lord dane to come it seems he came and i notice she's not making an
absolute statement that he came and since the confessor had placed the intention of the crucifixion
Jesus shared with me the pains of the cross and while doing this he said to the confessor
i was the administrator of the most holy trinity that is i administered to people the power the
wisdom and the love of the divine persons you being my representative must do nothing but
continue this my same work to souls and if you do not interest yourself you come to break the work
which i started and i feel defrauded in the execution of my designs and i'm forced to withdraw
the power the wisdom and the love which i would have administered to you had you carried out the
work that i entrusted to you so there's a very serious message to a priest
after this it seemed that Jesus transported me outside of myself and a multitude of people
could be seen from afar from whom a terrible stench came now here's your prophetic bit again
so it's Amos 3 7 and Isaiah 64 10 a terrible stench came from them Jesus said my daughter
what a division priests will cause among themselves so this stench is the sins of the clergy
this will be the last blow to foment parties and revolution among the people in other words the
division among the priests and he said this so embittered us to arouse compassion and then after
this remembering about my state i said to him tell me my lord do you want me to have the obedience
given to me to stop being in this state more so since no longer suffering as before i see myself
as useless now since this problem has been dealt with many times he said that's right
but he was so afflicted that my heart was restless as if i had not wanted him to tell me that
so i replied but lord it's not that i want to go out of it but i want to know your holy will because
my state was that you would come to me and share your sufferings with me but since this has ceased
i fear that you don't want me to continue to stay in bed and he just said you're right you're right
notice that he's not exactly happy with this conversation
but no i felt my heart crack because of the answers given to me by blessed jesus and i said
but my lord tell me at least what is your greater glory for me to continue to stay even if i should
die or to have the obedience to stop it given to me and jesus seeing that i wouldn't quit in other
words she should have known from his answers that this is a conversation he didn't want but uh she
persists and persists and she doesn't give up but seeing that i would not quit he changed the subject
himself by saying to me my daughter i feel offended by everyone see even devout souls have their
eyes on scrutinizing whether something is a sin or not now that's the screw velocity that was a
disease in the church at this particular time and it's one of the reasons why he doesn't want her
to keep on analyzing analyzing how she feels about the privation or whether she's in or out
whether she should get up and give it all up and all the rest and why he doesn't want to continue
the conversation that she started he says he feels offended by everything but as for amending
themselves rooting the sin out no a sign that there is neither sorrow nor love because sorrow
and love are the two most efficacious ointments which applied to the soul render her perfectly
healed luke 7 47 your sins are forgiven you go in peace
so jesus is saying here devout souls are priests and religious and and any of the laity living a
true spiritual life but they're they're caught up so much in this um screw velocity that they've
they've ended up giving all the attention to themselves uh what did i do what were the
circumstances did i give in didn't i give in if you go to confession and tell the priest you don't
know whether you gave in to a sin or not you're not going to confession confession is about a
confession of sin that requires forgiveness and so you can end up with these endless arguments as
to whether you did or you didn't and the priest doesn't know whether to give you absolution or not
uh jesus is going in higher volumes jesus is going to absolutely condemn this kind of behavior
as total a concentration on oneself which is destructive to love and destructive to the spiritual life
um but louisa said i was thinking about my here's jesus trying to tell her something important
and she said i was thinking about my poor position and i wanted to repeat it again in order to know
the will of the lord with clarity but jesus disappeared it was the only way to get away
and i returning inside myself saw myself all confused as to what to do so in order to be sure
i exposed everything to obedience which wants me to continue to stay i mean why does she go
around these roundabouts when she could ask the priest and the priest could tell her no problem
so december the 29th 1901 tribulations are necessary for one who lives in the shadow of jesus
so when we want to live a spiritual life trials and difficulties are necessary to make sure that
we are actually keep on the journey because you can fall down the mountain rather quickly
um so this is december the 29th 1901 louisa says as i was all oppressed i saw my adorable jesus
for just a little and looking at me he told me my daughter for one who lives in my shadow now that's
somebody actually not just living in the divine will but living in union with god
it is necessary that the winds of tribulations blow so that the infectious air around her
may not be able to penetrate into her even under my shadow
so by always agitating this unhealthy air the continuous winds keep it always far away
and make a most pure and solitary air flow having said this he disappeared and i understood many
things about this but it's not necessary to explain myself i want to give you sam 17 8
sam 57 1 sam 91 1
it's one of the signs that the lord is taking us seriously
that he allows tribulation to come to us and so if you think you can have a spiritual life
without the cross dogging your steps then you're deceiving yourself that's not actually possible
so let's go to january the sixth 1902 the portentous effects of uniting our lives with that of jesus
now we've had a recent message about this and so we just are being given a reminder here again
that if we truly want to add value to our lives then we need to unite all our thoughts words and
actions with those of jesus so that we gain his infinite merit january the sixth 1902
as i was in my usual state after much waiting my most beloved jesus came for just a little
and placing himself near me told me my daughter one who tries to conform to my life and everything
does nothing other than add one more and distinct fragrance to everything i did in my life okay
so i want to give you jan 14 7 that my disciples will do the same works as i do when i go to the
father um in such yeah in such a way as to perfume heaven and the whole church
and even the evil spirits themselves feel this celestial fragrance flow that's because they're
spirits this is so true that all the saints are nothing other than many fragrances
and are that which cheers the church and heaven because they are distinct among themselves
so one of the ways to describe the saints is to call them many fragrances it's not the only way
to describe them of course but it's just that he's talking about fragrance and so he wants to
continue to use that expression so we're supposed to add a fragrance to the church well the church
speaks about the odor or fragrance of sanctity and many people have experienced this i've certainly
experienced it in a wonderful death of a friend more than once where the the person was holy and
after they died there was a wonderful perfume in the room
um so among the the saints all the fragrances are different because they represent the major
virtue that the person had not only this but if one tries to continue my life by doing what i did
wherever he can and where he cannot at least with the desire and the intention
i keep it in my hands as if i were continuing my whole life in that soul not as something past
but as if i were living it now this is a treasure in my hands because as i double the treasure of
everything i operated i disposed for the good of the whole of mankind so everything in the divine
will is a universal vision nothing is small so you would want to be one of these he asks luisa
um that thing where he said that at least if you can't do something you could desire it
and you could place the intention that you'd like to do it saint rays of listu
who locked herself up in a caramelite convent for the whole of her life
in order to make reparation for priests she desired to be a missionary and to be a priest
and to be a teacher and to be a healer and to be all kinds of stuff and the lord actually allowed
that to be a reality he says if you want it i'll do it
luisa said that she saw herself all confused and didn't know what to answer but jesus disappeared
a little while later he came back and she saw many people who greatly feared death
on seeing this she said my beloved jesus it must be a defect in me this not fearing death
i see that others fear it so much while to me instead thinking of death that death would only
unite me with you forever and would put an end to the martyrdom of my heart separation
the thought of death not only gives no fear but is it is relief
yep you see most people don't love god as much as luisa and they most certainly have not had her
absolutely extraordinary experiences of god
so she continues it gives me peace and i make feast disregarding all other consequences which
death brings with itself and jesus said daughter in truth that extravagant fear of dying is foolishness
when one has all my merits virtues and works as a passport in order to enter heaven
would you please underline that in green white and gold
all jesus's merits virtues and works are our passport into heaven all we've got to do is make sure we
have the passport with us since i made a donation of it to everyone now you couldn't possibly
overemphasize that statement
those who have added from their own then profit even more from this donation of mine
and with all this substance what fear would you have of death now those who have added their own
means that they have loved the lord they have united their thoughts words and actions
movements and steps with his and they've done the place the intention of doing everything for
love of him so they've added more to the gift that jesus has given to them so why would you fear
rather with this most safe passport the soul can enter wherever she wants
and out of regard for her passport everyone respects her and lets her pass
now the everyone is everyone on the other side everyone in the kingdom of god they recognize
and notice it is out of regard for her passport it's not out of regard for us
we're not important at all but it's out of regard for her passport that everyone respects her
you are a person in christ and lets her pass as for you then you're not fearing death at all
comes from you're having dealt with me which of course is correct all her extraordinary
experiences with jesus okay and having experienced how sweet and dear is the union with the highest
good it's because of her personal experience no however that the most pleasing homage that can
be offered to me is desiring to die in order to be united with me which of course is her motivation
all the time this is the most beautiful disposition in order for the soul to be purged
and to pass straight on with no interval through on the way to heaven so the journey to heaven is
isiah 35 the whole 11 verses of it isiah 35 it's the highway to heaven you have two Corinthians 5
verses 1 to 10 and you have Philippians 3 verses 14 to 15 where Paul tells us to forget the past
strain for what is ahead and try and reach the price for which christ Jesus captured us
so that's a wonderful piece you're a passport to heaven
so January the 11th 1902 Jesus says that love must always be triple that means trinitarian
the father is love the son is love the holy spirit is love the whole trinity is love
and in this context we're going to bring up the law of divorce
this morning having received holy communion I saw my adorable Jesus for a little while
and as soon as I saw him I said to him my sweet good tell me do you continue to love me
that's absolutely extraordinary when you consider Jeremiah 31 3 I have loved you with an everlasting
love and I am constant forever in loving you and he said yes but I am loving and jealous so I want
to give you jealous love Exodus 20 verse 5 Exodus 34 verse 14 Deuteronomy 5 9 and also Deuteronomy
6 verses 4 to 10 you shall love the Lord your God with all your heart all your soul all your mind
and all your being in other words he doesn't tolerate you mixing some other love with it
so he said yes I am loving and jealous jealous and loving even more I tell you that in order to be
perfect love must be triple perfect means complete and in me there are these triple conditions
of love okay the first one he said is that I love you as creator as redeemer and as a lover
secondly I love you in my omnipotence which I used in creating you and in creating everything
for love of you now notice that everything was created for you in such a way that air water fire
and everything else tell you that I love you so we have to look around us and realize that everything
is proclaiming his love and that I made them for love of you I love you as my image
Louisa learned how to use that knowledge in order to mitigate some Justicesments
my image of course is Genesis 1 27 Romans 8 29 and I love you out of regard for you individually
now notice that's not the first thing he says it's way down the line
thirdly I love you ab a eternal from eternity that's Jeremiah 31 3 I love you in time that's
John 13 chapter 13 to chapter 17 and I love you for all eternity and this is nothing but a
breath John 20 22 that came out of my love imagine yourself what must be the love I contain within
myself now you are obliged to return to me this triple love that's your Deuteronomy 6 4 to 10
you must love me as your god in whom you must fix all of yourself you must let nothing come
out of you which is not love for me loving me out of regard for yourself and for the good that
comes to you and loving me for all and in all after this Jesus transported me outside of myself
she said and I found myself in the midst of many people who were saying if this law that's the law
of divorce that was threatening to come in in 1902 if this law was confirmed a confirmed poor woman
everything will turn out bad for her all were anxiously waiting to hear the pros and the cons
and in another separate place many people could be seen who were discussing among themselves
one of them took the floor and reduced everyone to silence and after much struggling he went out
the door and he said yes indeed in favor of the woman on hearing this all those who were outside
made feast and those were inside remained all confused the ones inside wanted the divorce the
ones outside didn't so much so that they did not have the courage even to go out I believe that
this is the law of divorce which they're talking about and I understood that they did not confirm
it January the 11th 1902 they did confirm it in the end of course so January the 12th 1902
we're still talking about divorce it seems my adorable Jesus continues to come a little bit
this morning then transporting me outside of myself he showed me the great evils of society
and his great bitterness and he poured into me abundantly part of what embittered him
then he said to me my daughter see how where the blindness of men has reached right now
to the point of wanting to make laws which are iniquitous this is the law of divorce
and go against themselves and their own social welfare want to give you Isaiah 520
and Isaiah 7 verses 15 and 16 and Isaiah 13 11 my daughter this is why I am calling you to
sufferings again so that as you offer yourself with me to divine justice you must fight this
law of divorce though sorry those who must fight this law of divorce may obtain light and efficacious
grace in order to be victorious my daughter I tolerate that they make wars and revolutions
and that the blood of new martyrs inundate the world this is an honor for me and my church
but this brutal law of divorce is an affront to my church it is abominable and intolerable to me
Matthew 5 32 Matthew 19 verses 1 to 9
now while Jesus was saying this I saw a man who was fighting against this law tired and exhausted
in the act of wanting to withdraw from the enterprise so together with the lord we encouraged him that
should be a small h I am and he answered I see myself almost fighting alone and unable to obtain
the intent and I said to him courage for contradictions are as many pearls which the lord will use to
adorn you in heaven and he took heart and continued the enterprise after this I saw someone else all
weary and concerned not knowing what to decide and someone saying to him do you know what they
should do get out get out of Rome and he said no I cannot this is the word given to me by my father
I will lay down my life but as for getting out never in other words get out of the chart
afterwards we withdrew Jesus disappeared and I found myself inside of myself
January the 14th 1902 one is not worthy of Jesus if he does not empty himself of every
thing now this goes back right back to volume one and volume two
as I was in my usual state my adorable Jesus came and told me my daughter only one who has
emptied himself of everything and has filled himself completely with me can be truly worthy of me
in such a way as to make of himself an object of divine love alone
so if we want to become an object of divine love then we know what to do get rid of everything
that's not divine get rid of the world get rid of self
to make himself an object of divine love to the point that my love must come to form his life
and that he must love me not with his love but with my own love now our love as we know is useless
but we learn with the divine will to love Jesus with his own love at his own level
then he added what do these words mean he has cast down the mighty from their thrones
and lifted up the lowly which of course is in Luke chapter one in the Magnificat
that the soul destroying herself that's destroying her ego completely fills all of
herself with God and as she loves God with God himself God exalts the soul to an eternal love
it is true and it is the greatest exaltation and also true humility now this God exalts the soul
to an eternal love is John 15 9 I have loved you with an everlasting love
as the Father has loved me so I have loved you that is eternally absolutely unconditionally
this is the true and the greatest exaltation and also true humility
as is obvious in our ladies Magnificat as well that the almighty has done great things for
for his lowly handmade
so let's read that again because it's very important
that the soul destroying her ego completely fills all of herself with God and as she loves God
with God himself God exalts the soul to an eternal love the only baggage allowed in heaven
this is the true and greatest exaltation and also true humility and then he continued
the true sign to know whether one possesses this love is that the soul cares about nothing
but loving God and making him known now there is your key to understanding it
so the soul cares about nothing but loving God and making him known and making everyone love him
then as he withdrew into my interior I heard him say
oh this most beautiful prayer and we'll finish with this ever wholly and indivisible trinity
I adore you profoundly I love you intensely I thank you perpetually for all and in the hearts
of all amen and I went on in this way hearing him pray almost continuously inside of me
and I with him so I want to leave it there for now
so